hello and welcome to this video playing
Charm City chess okay okay the g6 lawyer
I'm always worried about this when I
look at this from the black point of
view I wonder about the correct move
although I think this is right and Queen
takes yes we should be for this is how
they play it do your castle or queen III
I don't know 23 maybe 95 there is soup
d8 yes okay that's a bad idea but this
is right getting out of this I don't
want you don't want to allow the
doubling of the pond so easily so let's
say f3 here do I go long or short whom
probably castles long here till how to
play it maybe like this in general
traits are chair welcome in this
position here for me the check the
ending here on without queens let's say
it's usually okay for black it's not a
big problem this this issue with the
with the pawn structure okay i don't
really like it here but i didn't i'm
slightly slightly passer here with age
three I didn't like g3 either due to
Queen h5 well we'll see
midnight on d1 and midnight on b3 they
are not good pieces I need to regroup
them yeah possibly night a fourth round
the corner
yeah I'm putting a knight to e 3 here
covering g2 not happy with my play at
all it's probably not a big deal but
yeah yeah the night doesn't have have
squares
yeah a 491 a 3 maybe but I might be able
to just take that pawn I think a 3 I can
take it's not a big problem at all yeah
let's get this to e3 oh good move Wow ok
didn't see that one coming but it's a
good move can I go back
I couldn't take on d4 sg2 was was
hanging
I think maybe 92 is something that he's
he's out for him okay but I don't know
what I have 95 against this which should
be still kind of okay
yeah it looks like I'm worse and he's
kind of old playing me here I'm not sure
how bad it really is
if you just play something like yeah
maybe something something like that yes
King be seven or something like that
then it's kind of hard for me to to do
anything anything meaningful oh that's
surprising that he puts it on a light
square here Wow okay light will come to
see three now and that's a good square
fallen for the night not sure maybe that
was a cat too ambitious here for black
so i can try to kick the Queen away with
this and Queen d2 not sure about it I'm
not sure about it at all now yes going
to have six in some cases yeah here
but maybe Quinn g301 a Quincy three days
Quincy three actually don't don't want
that
gee 396 the f fire I think this is
probably right yeah 22 hours thinking
trade should be fine Quincy five though
we have this is more interesting if
they're probably better also time
morning
I d2s them with some chimes hmm don't
know what to do here against this Wow
strong I cannot take I am stupid okay I
is having the check well very strong why
no I just hope let me in this game I
mean probably I was I was okay I mean I
was better again later but like around
here I'm why this white is starting to
be better again I think so engine is
giving its it's just equal okay maybe I
have no way to way forward but I mean
here around here I'm really
uncomfortable to this between before and
so on but I felt he made some
over-ambitious moves like c4 after that
only only wider than can be can be
better the bishop now looks pretty bad
and it's possible that there is no way
forward I mean night c4k this is what
the engine is giving didn't calculate
this line that means a pawn okay Jim no
I was more I was trying to improve the
position but this was good now am the
engine wants me to go back this was a
bad idea f5 was very strong very strong
move and I didn't spot that idea at all
this was this was the idea I have to go
back to c3 be called that and here I'm
losing
what is this guy never played it before
yeah not a very frequent play in the
five from the five pool so can happen
pretty new account I guess hmm yeah what
was nicely played at TM I'm just losing
be shipped in five is even stronger than
stronger than this is also wins but
Bishop g5 is a lot better so how did I
probably I was through to trade yeah i
was i was trading thing this in the two
simple way back with rookie da then
hooked you one I mean you can't do that
but probably you're giving up on the
idea of having it an edge and here it
was it was a bit uncomfortable I mean I
don't think I'm I worse or anything but
it's not really a great position for
white okay thanks for watching